too
トゥデイ
さあ形マシュー
ブーバペ
んんーっやーねーえっ
a
よっちゃんっえっ
姉さん姉性能を好きにどうぞ
8ちょっとっ
えええええええ
えっえっ
半分でございますよ半分でございましょう続けて続けて
続けて続けてえっ
んさんっ
a
いやーねー
移りましょう純明ですからきまーす1
あっせーの声オオ店ねええええ
おっ
our 熱い生のチェン税
ぼーっとしてるときますが当然できますよ愛生の好投
汗の高台部
シェーンのジェン j ポロえええっねーっ
んおお
えっっ
ああああああ
きゅっきゅっきゅっにゃーんっ年キング
はいっえっおおぉ
えええ
イェイイェイラボがわー
さあ今のは一体何だったんでしょうか
ねえその話は後ほど多いときまして私は
もりぶですこれはグリムですけどねもう友達なんです何か良いものですから
そんな僕が
ぐりぶーと呼ばれ始めたちが盛りふぐて貼り始めた
小学校の時にですね
そう時間に廊下でバケツをひっくりかえしてどんどこどんどこただ行ったらもちろん
先生に叱られましたけど
その時の快感が忘れずに
今に至っているわけです
そして
中学校に入って新聞配達してドラムセットを買ってそのまま
バングを活動を始めました
で9鹿児島大学
ジャズバンド学部に入学しまして
あーちゃすバンド学部じゃないですね
あの工学部に入学しますですね9工学部建築学科を卒業しましてそれから建設現場の
現場監督を
7年間やってましたその現場監督7年目にですねー
はしごから7名だー店ロクス転落するという事故を今して7ヶ月入院するという
777というトリプルセブン非常に縁起の良い体験をさせていただきましですね
これは建築の世界はちょっと厳しいなと思って足を払ったわけですけど
それから縁がありますでインターネットの仕事を10年やってました
ネットを使って人と人とがつながっていく仕事がとても面白くて楽しかったんですけど
それも78年経った頃今からちょうど10年ぐらい前ですけど40歳以降をどうやって
世の中に役に立っていこうかなと思い始めました
当日もうその会社の役員してたんでそのまま会社の経営を引き継いで経営者になるのか
もしくは自分なりの価値を新たな価値を見出して独立して
やっていくのかどちらかなーと思ってたそんな10年前に
偶然ドラムサークルというプログラムに出会いました
ドラムサークルというのはドラムセットの
愛好会同好会て意味ではなくてこの絵のように
いろんな人がはになって世界中の大綱を叩くというだけのことなんですけど
その10年前にドラム作品で行った時本当に驚いたんですね
何驚いだかと言うとその場で行われたこと
実際の子供それから一般の大人
それからお年寄り
って障害を持っている方
それが日本語全然しゃべれない外国人みんな一緒になってリズムを共有して楽しい音楽
を作ってたんですね
それ僕はびっくりすでとなり炎症に聞いてみました
よく参加されるんですか4今日初めて来ました
でもなんか楽器されたことあるんですよね4学期全然したことで筐体以降初めて触った
んですよ
本当ですか
別な人にも訪ねていきましょう
皆さんもしれないですかいや初めて会った人たちばかりです
僕はびっくりステイ
そこで
今日初めて会った人同士ほとんどが合致やったことない人たち
で子どもと大人という異世代間交流
外国人と日本人という国際交流そして健常者と障害者という人たちの交流
人間がつながりはなければならないところでリズムがすごく役に立って一つになって
全て行われたんですね
いろんな人たち同士の交流が
これは今からの世の中4 a
人間同士が仲良くなっていくためにはすごく必要になると思ってこれ鹿児島に持ち替え
てやろうと思ったんですね
でもその当時は今のように仕事として取り組むとは思ってませんでした
土日の週末に自分の演奏活動の延長線上でやっていけたらなぁと思ってたんですけど
いろんな書籍やビデオ取り寄せて
毎朝4時半5時に起きて2時間便ずつ勉強する日々が始まったんですけど色々そういっ
たリズムとか
音楽のことを勉強すると特にずむのほどいろんな今まで知らなかった事が今すごく
わかってきました
特にリズムが人間の心と体に作用するいろんな効能についてですね
そして
これはもしかしたら自分の得意なリズムというのがいま世の中にある
いろんな人間の心に起因する様々な社会問題
子どもたちにとってはいじめとか大人たちにとっては
うつによる自殺とか
そういう社会問題をいくらかでも軽減できるお手伝いができるんじゃないかなと思った
んですね
それならこれはもう真剣に仕事自分の仕事として取り組んでビジネスとして取り組んで
いこうという決意を持って1年置きして40歳の時に独立してこの仕事を始めました
もちろん独立で3年間はですねほとんどお金もらえる仕事はなくてそれはもう苦労し
ましたね
だけど今はおかげさまでいろんな現場でこういったリズムによる心身の活性化の活動を
させていただいています
こういった野外イベントであるとか
こういった社員研修であるとか
それからこういった大規模な全国規模のカンファレンスのクロージングであるとか
高させていただきます
でも普段日常的に関わっている現場は福祉の現場
知的障害者施設においてはいろんな音楽活動社会にされているのはみなさんご存知の
ことと思いますが
聴覚に障害を持つ子どもたちでとキッズと言われています
そういった長が聴覚に障害を持っている子どもたちと一般の方々をつなげるドラム
サークル分
聴覚に障害をもっても視覚でリズムを捉えますそれから触覚でリズムを捉えます
何も白ができないと繋がりある買えないということはないです
リズムをみんなで共有すればコミュニケーションがとれて楽しいバーが作れる
そういった活動を行っていますしあと医療の分野医療の分野では僕はほとんどと言い
ますか
全部精神科の分野のですが高齢者施設の認知症を患ったおじいちゃんおばあちゃんたち
リズムとか昔懐かしい曲で刺激を与えると突然覚醒しだして
を忘れた家族の名前思い出した
ということが実際に起きます
2は去年公開されましたパーソナルソングという映画にドキュメンタリーにもなってい
ますのでぜひ機会があったら観ていただきたいと思うんです
それから
うつ病のデイケアですね
うつ病な患者さんたちどよーんとしています
だけど太鼓の音がなってくると
体がだんだんと大きい始めます
何だろうと思って目を開けるとそこに太鼓がいい
でもどうやって言うのかわからないので最初は太古の上に手を乗せてみる
そしたら周りから
ゆったりとしたどんど行動ん状態を聞こえてくるので振動を伝わってきます
それでリズムを感じ始めると試しにドーンとたたえてみよう
早々と向こうの人がドーンと退会してくれる
今度はどんどん伝えてみよう向こうの人がどんどんと返してくる
そうやってリズムによるコミュニケーションができてきます
そうするとだんだんと体が覚えてきて皆さんとそこにいる人たちと繋がりあう
そうすると沈んでた表情がだんだんと口角がてにこやかな表情になってくる
そういう変化が実際に置きますこれは事実です
それから精神科の入院病棟ですね昔は精神病と言ってましたが今は統合失調症とか
自律神経失調症どうとかいう病名がついています
そういった患者さんたち
そういった患者さんたちの作業量大プログラムとして
ドラムサーク取り組んでいただいているんですけどいろんな作業療法のプログラムあり
ます
編み物をしたりとか焼き物を焼いたりとか
卓球したりとかカラオケ行ったりとか
そういう一般的な作業療法プログラム
一切やろうとしない患者さん
ですけど作業療法室から
ゆったりとしたリズムが流れてきます作業療法室ぼーんしてないですから
良質なでなんとなく聞こえていくんですね
そしたらぬくって起き上がって
だんだんと足がその音楽室に音楽療法画質でね
作業療法室の方に水をされるように近づいていく
僕中学校の時に大好きなスタンリーキューブリック監督
それから弱ニコルソン主演の
カッコーの巣の上でトレバー見て大変衝撃を受けました
っっ
こんな世界があるんだと思う
で今私が関わっている精神科入院病棟まさしくその映画の通りの世界です
作業療法室から患者さん達が家帰ってくるのを見ていると本当に
こうゆっくりなリズムで3人4人とどんどん掃除等が増えていくんですね
まさしくあの映画の世界です
そういう患者さんたちの変化をいくらかでも治療に役立ててもらえないかなと思って
この活動を続けています
まだ一般には作業療法プラグのプログラムとして認知されていませんけど
ぜひいろんな精神科の先生方とか大学の先生方とかがいい
研究していただいてですねそのエビデンスの確率を持って全国に広めていただけたらな
というふうに思っています
そして教育現場ですねちっさな
子どもたち幼稚園香育園の子どもたちから小学校中学校高校大学といろんな場で活動さ
せていただいてますけどそういった大人への神田階段を一歩一方
文進めるにしたがってなぜか子どもたちというのは自由な表現とか
旺盛な好奇心というのを失ってい
黒です
処方僕がそういったリズムロバでスイッチを入れてあげることによっていくらかでも
その歯止めを掛けてあげたいな
大人になっても子供の時のような好奇心
子供の時の裏 x な表現力を持って世の中に出ることでいろんな革新的なアイディア
とか
皆さんが共有できるような素晴らしい上げを持って世の中を革新的なところに連れて
行ってくれるんじゃないかなという思いで子どもたちの現場もやってます
こんなことがありました
ある
決して偏差値高いと言えないような高校です
夏の暑い時でした
男子高校生胸をハゲ
女子高校生のスカートをヒラヒラパターまだ
先ほどのように皆さんのようにすぐには反応してくれません全く無視されている状態
四面楚歌ところではないですねでもそういう箱そう僕はもうやりますね絶対あきらめ
ないぞね
絶対諦めないなぜなら僕は仕事をしてきてるのでこの後各成立させないと
ネッツ議会仕事いただけない家族6人で
食っていくためには必須ですね
もう後半も後半も差し掛かった頃ようやく音楽好きな高校生が
音何人か56人なんとなく付き合ってリズムセッションを始めてくれます
そういう音が出始めると壁際でふんぞり返った高校生脚組んで
表情は変わらないですがその組んでた足がピコーンてぃコーン
反応しないんで僕はそれを見た家それでいいんだよねっ
で音を出してくれた高校生も帰り際に
学級を片付けるのを手伝ってくれました
大分さん今日はほんとすいませんせっかく来ていただいたのにもっと叩き方があったん
ですけどいいのへのそういう変化が大臣
ねでそういった子たちが世の中に出てリズムでスイッチを入れなければならない時に
きっとその時のことを思い出してくれたらなぁと思います
さあ最初の皆さんのテーブルドラミングクラッピングね
あれはなんだったんでしょうかいろんなスイッチが入っていたことと思います
リズムによって
この場を楽しもうというスイッチかもしれません
横と前にるすぐ綱五郎というスイッチかもしれませんね
せっかく来たんで何かを持ち帰ろうとし1だったかもしれません
そういったリズムによるスイッチをどんどん意識して増やしてほしいなあというのが
今日の私のテーマです
でも無意識に皆さん日常的によとかはっとかね
掛け声によって人と息を合わせるとか言う
リズムによるスイッチは入れられていることと思いますそれをよし
より意識して増やしていただきたいと
いうことです
お家に帰ったとき
暗い室内電灯のスイッチを入れるのもただなにげに入れるんじゃなくて
4広い玄関がある人はターンして近江だねっ
そうするといつもより上がりおいしいになるんじゃないかなというふうに思っています
けどそれからあのー往生したりとかを選択したりとか
女性の方だろ
お仕事をしたいとそういうときに偶然ラジオから聞こえるリズム
音楽によってリズムよくねっ何か作業がはかどったような気分になったこと皆さんご
経験あるかと思います
それは実際にはかどってるんです時間が短縮されているんです
これは昔から研究されててなんと100年ぐらい前に
ドイツの l クラゲ酢先生がかかりましたリズムの本質という本があります今も出版
されてますけどそれに書かれているのは音楽のリズムのことはあまり書いてなくて
人間の心と体のリズムとか宇宙のリズムとか
環境のリズムとか
それからこういった建築のテクスチャのリズムであるとか
それから同一の先生ですの工業製品の製造ラインのリスクとか
あらゆる人間社会生活の中にリズムが介在してそれがリズムが人間を支配していると
まで書いてあります
あと
貧乏い3ですね音もつまんない話でなんかつまんないなぁと思いの loving 種
されている人ももしかしたらいるかもしれませんけど
8割はタッピング効果と言いますですねあの人間の気持ちを落ち着かせるという作用が
あるとされていますね
一般的には良くないこととされてますけど気持ちが落ち着くんですね
貧乏ゆすりある吹きそこに挑んなんとやってるとなかなかいいなと思います
なんか信号を送っているのかなきゃーっ
ん
それから皆さんが生まれてから亡くなるまでずーっと刻み続ける
心臓の子ドアりますねこれはどっくんどっくんどっくん
三拍子ですどっくんこれにみなさんが健康な方は移動するときに必ず使う歩行という
リズムこれは足が2本あるので自然に魅了しです心臓のリズムの三拍子と歩行のリズム
の二拍子
特訓
どっくんどっくん
10て作ってずんっずんって付けてトゥに秒した3業種が重なるとアフリカンポリーズ
んですねアフリカのスタンダードリズムになります
不思議ですねなのでリズム感がないとおっしゃっている方ね
いらっしゃると言いますけどリズム感がない人はいないんです皆さんリズムを持って
いるんですね
なので
そういう自己完結型のリズムだけじゃなくて人とつながるときもね
ぜひリズムで水中でて欲しいと思いますあうんの呼吸ツーカーの仲
ね今日の会議つまんなそうだなぁと思ったら先ほど面ケーブルドラミングやりましょう
ねっ
いろんな愛在がどんどん出てきて会議も早く終わってねその間によって会社の業績は
ドーンとアップみたいなね
そして宴会ね宴会では三本締めよくありますけど始まりにもやりましょう今日の
打ち上げでもぜひやりましょう
one two three カンパーイそうすると円買いもドーンと盛り上がって
早く終わって早く家に帰って健康にもいいということになる方ですとにかく今の自分
リズムの中で見つめるとリズムの中でちょっと先
ちょっと先の未来に対して
リズムでスイッチを得る
というお話でしたじゃあを終えにを終えのスイッチもリズムで t たいと思います皆
さんご協力入っえっ
ハイブーツ ii 数値ウルフ
ありがとうご座さあ